The original version of Pixar's Luca was going
to be very different, from a huge monster
movie ending, to a quest for magical tokens,
and a missing John Ratzenberger cameo.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the alternate ending
of Luca and some of the scenes and storylines
you never got to see!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Before Pixar's filmmakers landed on the beautiful
bittersweet ending for Luca we see in the
final film, the movie's finale was originally
going to be more of a giant monster battle.
This particular story leaned much more heavily
than the final film into the division between
humans and seas monsters, setting them up
as two diametrically opposed factions or worlds,
which director Enrico Casarosa compared in
an interview with SlashFilm to the divide
between the Capulets and Montagues in Romeo
& Juliet.
Although in the final film the townspeople
of Portorosso are still fearful of sea monsters
with a reward being set up after a recent
sighting of one, it sounds like in the earlier
version this confrontation between the two
worlds was going to be even more intense,
with the original plan being for Alberto to
transform into a kraken, an enormous mythical
sea monster that looks like a humungous octopus
or squid, with Luca then standing up to defend
and protect his friend.
However, as Casarosa told Cinema Blend a conversation
he had with his own real-life best friend
ended up inspiring him to completely retool
the film's finale.
That movie-changing chat was all about their
own friendship and how good friends help each
other grow but eventually that often takes
them down very different paths in life, leading
to bittersweet goodbyes.
For Casarosa, that's something he's experienced
several times in his own life, having left
his home in Italy for America to pursue his
dreams of animation and filmmaking.
And when he and his team put those ideas together,
storyboarded them, and added composer Dan
Romer's score, they were hit by just how emotional
it was.
So, the film dropped its colossal kraken and,
as Casarosa told SlashFilm, focused instead
on "a kid's world and stakes and goals, with
this kind of slightly strange and silly idea:
"We're gonna ride into the sunset with a Vespa!"
Curiously enough, in the final film there
is actually an easter egg to a giant sea monster
movie though, via the poster for the Disney
adaption of Jules Vernes' "20,000 Leagues
Under The Sea", which features an attack by
a giant squid.
And there's also an illustration of a giant
kraken-like creature wrapping its tentacles
around a boat on one of the fishermen's maps.
Over the years, Krakens have popped up in
quite a few well-known movies including The
Clash of The Titans, the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise, and Hotel Transylvania 3: Summer
Vacation,
which is funny as the protagonists of both
that movie and Luca are monsters and both
films are set during the summer holidays!
In fact, the kraken plays a key part in the
ending of the third Hotel Transylvania movie,
and given that film came out in 2018 while
Luca was still in development at Pixar, I
wonder if it might have also influenced the
decision to change Luca’s finale.
When Casarosa first came up with the idea
for the movie, Luca and Alberto were not the
only young sea monsters who featured in the
story;
there was actually a group of them, giving
the film what the director has called a Stand
By Me vibe, referring to the 1980s coming-of-age
classic.
In fact, one of those additional sea monster
friends was called Ciccio, a name you'll probably
recognise from the final film as his original
role was completely rewritten to make him
one of bully boy Ercole's human side-kicks
instead.
And there's a lot of lovely concept art by
Chris Sasaki which shows the original trio
of Luca, Alberto and Ciccio getting up to
various hijinks in both their sea monster
and human forms.
Judging by Ciccio's build in the final film,
it looks like this character here was the
sea monster version of him.
It's interesting that sea monster Ciccio had
crab claws for arms and carried around a shell
on his back, like a hermit crab.
And a remnant of this original idea made its
way into Luca's surname "Paguro" which means
hermit crab in Italian.
As for Giulia, it seems a human girl was part
of the group of male sea monster friends even
in early versions of the story;
however, the filmmakers did experiment with
when exactly to reveal the truth to her that
her new pals were not actually human.
You can see in the Art of Luca book that at
one point she learned about them earlier as
she goes swimming with them in their sea monster
form.
And in another scene she's with all three
original sea creature friends and they have
their tails showing as they sit down for dinner
with Massimo.
In the end, Casarosa and his team decided
that prolonging that reveal till later in
the film "added more tension and drama", as
producer Andrea Warren told website io9.
In what would have been another major change
to the story, originally the kids went on
a much bigger quest that involved magical
tokens and their intention was to become completely
human.
The final film certainly has shades of The
Little Mermaid with Alberto collecting items
from the human world and Luca being forbidden
from going to the surface, but it sounds like
this original plot point would have made the
film feel even more like Pixar's The Little
Merman.
Likewise, Luca's original storyline where
the young sea monsters set out to become fully-fledged
human boys also has a ring about it of the
Italian children's novel Pinocchio, which
was adapted into a movie by Disney.
And there are several easter eggs to the wooden
marionette who desperately wanted to become
a real human boy in the finished Pixar film.
However, Casarosa says that storyline got
too complicated and he preferred a "more lyrical
take on things".
So, he decided to strip everything back to
what he realised should be the heart of the
film: the friendship between Luca and Alberto,
and he made those two children the centre
of the story.
Further work was still needed on the characters
because, as Luca's a bit introverted and very
quiet, Casarosa found that in some earlier
versions of the script, it was difficult for
the audience to understand him.
So, subconsciously inspired by his love of
Fellini's film 8½ and its dream sequences,
for the final film Casarosa decided to take
us literally inside Luca's head by showing
us his daydreams.
Another thing that evolved during development
was where the sea monsters lived.
Originally, they were "hiding in plain sight"
in their own town on an island, as you can
see in this concept art here from the Art
of Luca book.
And another piece of concept art shows how
the monster island was shaped like an octopus.
However, Casarosa and his team decided they
only needed one town, so they "just let the
sea monsters be well-hidden" instead.
They did still keep the idea of an island
though, but just as the location of Alberto's
tower, and there may be another trace of the
original concept in the way that one of the
fishermen is afraid to go there.
"Do we really need to fish near the island?"
"You worry too much."
"I don't know.
What if the old stories are true?"
Some other interesting alternatives that were
considered for the monster world are these
illustrations of an underwater town that is
similar in look to the human town and which
appears to be situated almost directly underneath
Portorosso.
Again there appears to be a remnant of this
original idea on the back of the playing card
that Luca finds which has the picture of a
town in the top half which is reflected in
the lower half.
There was also an alternative to Alberto's
tower for his collection of human objects
in the form of a secret hideout inside an
upside-down semi-submerged shipwreck.
The entrance was via the water with a dry
area in the hull above where Alberto stored
his whosits and whatsits.
And it looks like the boat was located in
a cave, again giving it a bit of a Little
Mermaid vibe.
A regular Pixar feature that didn't make it
into the final movie is a cameo by John Ratzenberger.
Before Soul, the Cheers actor had voiced at
least one character in every Pixar film.
In Soul, Ratzenberger didn't voice any character;
however, the movie's co-director Kemp Powers
said that a tribute to him was made via a
non-speaking character who appears briefly
in the subway.
As for Luca, Casarosa confirmed that Ratzenberger
is not in the film and said on Twitter that
he hoped to start a new tradition of having
The Good Dinosaur director Peter Sohn voice
a character in each new Pixar movie.
In Luca, Sohn is the voice of Ciccio.
"Well, my head kinda hurts..."
"Not you, Ciccio!"
I'm curious as to whether Ratzenberger has
now retired from Pixar films for good or if
his absence from Soul and Luca is related
to the pandemic as both films were completed
during that time.
Intriguingly, I found an old man sea monster
character in some concept art that I wonder
if he might have played.
And if you want to discover all the Pixar
easter eggs which did make it into Luca, tap
here to watch my full Things You Missed video.
And my next video will be all the incredible
deleted scenes from Raya and the Last Dragon
which I'll link here and in the video description
too.
And if you want to check out more of the gorgeous
concept art from Luca, there's also links
in the description where you can get the Art
of Luca book.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
or story ideas had been in the final movie?
Let me know what you think in the comments.
And if you enjoyed this, then do like and
subscribe, it's hugely appreciated!
Next you can tap left to learn all of the
hidden messages and meanings in the ending
of Luca, including what Alberto's secret catchphrase
really means.
Or tap right for another Disney deleted scenes
video.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!